Michael we often talk about the maturity
leaps the players make in their third or
fourth season and I remember having a
lot of those conversations about Jamal
at the time what's the maturity leap now
that he's in his sixth season because
there's that other level right yeah I
mean it's uh I think I hope that we're
all getting better yeah I mean I'm
trying to get better I mean I never want
to stop learning I want to never want to
stop growing and you could say the same
thing for Nicola who was a two-time MVP
finding ways to improve and for Jamal
the biggest thing this year Rachel was
getting healthy
and then being back healthy then getting
over the mental hurdle of reminding
myself I can get back to not just the
level I was at in the bubble but how do
I surpass that
and that was I remember being in the bus
with him going to the airport after he
did the injury in Golden State the next
day and he had tears in his eyes and
that was the message hey man you're
going to come back from this and not
only are you going to come back you're
going to be better
and that's that's in that moment it's
really hard to believe that his first
thought was man are you guys going to
trade me
and I really and that was his
I'm damaged goods are you guys gonna
trade me now and I hugged him I said
hell no like your hours we love you
we're going to help you get back and
you're going to be a better player for
it and I think what he's doing in these
playoffs is just a reminder of
um a guy that we drafted seven years ago
that has continued to find ways to
improve and really show out on the
biggest stage in the world